today on the matt walsh show there's
been a dramatic increase
in violent incidents on airplanes
there's also been a dramatic increase in
violent incidents
everywhere else uh in the country what
does all this add up to we'll talk about
that
also five headlines joe biden continues
to mentally decay in front of the world
if you haven't seen the latest video of
this it's pretty startling
caitlyn jenner says that he's the victim
of transphobia from the left are the
dems in fact
the real transphobes and cnn's anna
navarro defends public masturbator
jeffrey tubin her defense is uh pretty
pathetic
finally in our daily cancellation we'll
discuss the increasing efforts to
normalize
so-called sex work aka prostitution all
of that and more today on the matt walsh
show
[Music]
so what are you gonna do about the fact
that uh it seems like every company
especially this month is going full woke
well one of the things you could do
is find the um the gloriously unwoke
companies and i mean that
in in the best way possible and support
them one of them is charity mobile you
have to worry about charity mobile doing
the woke thing they're not going to do
it
one company that fits the description of
of a company that's on our side the
culture wars charity mobile that's the
pro-life phone company
five percent of your monthly plan price
goes to the pro-life pro family charity
of your choice
and what that means is that you're
helping to build a culture of life
in america while supporting a pro-life
phone company and you're also getting
a great service on top of that i can
attest to i've been a charity mobile
customer for
i don't know a year now or something and
it's been a great experience
a lot of perks you get new activations
and eligible accounts get a free cell
phone with free activation
and free shipping there's no contracts
there's no termination fees and there's
no risk with a 30-day guarantee there's
also a live customer service base right
here in the usa
which is good for a number of reasons
also it's american jobs so
another reason to support charity mobile
this is nationwide service on america's
largest and most reliable 4g lte network
so call them at 1-877-474-3662 or chat
with them online at charitymobile.com
you may not have heard about this
incident but it seems pretty notable to
me or at least
it should be notable newsweek has the
report it says a delta airlines pilot
asked
strong males to help subdue a problem
passenger
who turned out to be an off-duty flight
attendant during a chaotic flight from
los angeles to atlanta on friday
a delta spokesperson reportedly said the
unnamed off-duty flight attendant
hijacked the plane's public address
system to speak to passengers about
their oxygen masks during flight 1730
which prompted a dramatic tussle with
passengers
the pilot told passengers according to
nbc this is the captain speaking
we'd like all strong males to come to
the front of the aircraft to handle a
problem passenger
now what does that tell you by the way
all strong males
you know you notice he called for strong
males he didn't call for any women
because in
in that moment when you're up 30 000
feet in the air
and there's something happening and
needs to be contained there's no time to
worry about political correctness it's
let's get we need the strong guys here
um that's kind of interesting that's not
really the point though video of the
chaos was posted to twitter by a
passenger who witnessed it and she
posted the clip explaining quote that um
someone tried to hijack our plane from
lax to atlanta
so that's what she said hijack the plane
here's what that video looks like
let's watch a little bit of it
all three of them
okay so you see a whole bunch of guys
can't really see much
this is certainly the kind of thing you
don't want to see when you're on an
airplane
all right and eventually eventually they
contained the guy and then they they
made an emergency landing and uh
there you go now
you look at that video and you hear the
story if you feel like you already
heard this same story a few weeks ago
and saw a video kind of like that
that's because you did or something very
similar to it in that case
it was a flight also from la this was a
two weeks ago or so you may be noticing
a pattern both both of these are from la
this time it was heading to nashville
and a quote unruly passenger tried to
break into the cockpit
and was tackled and restrained by a
group of flight attendants
now these alleged attempted hijackings
or whatever they were
may not have been very sophisticated and
they may not have had any real chance of
success it's not like the plane was ever
in any danger of
being taken down but still two in less
than a month
seems like a lot and in fact a lot
doesn't begin to cover it there's been a
huge rise in violent
and dangerous behavior on flights they
mostly aren't attempted hijackings but
even so the figures cited by newsweek in
the same article
are just outrageous and almost
impossible to believe listen to this
quoting out says in early may the
federal aviation administration warned
air travelers about a significant rise
in dangerous behavior aboard flights on
in 2021 there are usually 100 to 150
official instances of unruly
passengers passenger behavior in a
typical year
but listen to this that figure leaped to
more than
1300 in the first four months
of this year according to the agency
1300
in four months as opposed to 100 or so
in a whole year
in fact a bbc article says that u.s
airlines have reported 3
000 unruly passengers this year
now there might be a distinction being
drawn here between dangerous and unruly
which may explain the disparity
but whether we're looking at 1300 or
3000 there's obviously something going
on here
a part of the problem is certainly the
masking policies i would guess a certain
number of those unruly passengers may
have simply been not wearing a mask
or not wearing it correctly and were
categorized as unruly and kicked off the
plane
i don't know of all these toddlers we
see getting kicked off planes because
they're not wearing masks are
do they go down in the books officially
as unruly i don't know
and certain other instances certain
other passengers
in these videos uh have become unruly
because of disputes over masks
and in general flying is a high stress
situation in a claustrophobic
environment already
any additional annoyances or discomforts
added like having to wear a muzzle on
your face the whole time
will only increase the likelihood of
confrontations so that must account for
some of the rise
in dangerous behavior on flights but it
probably doesn't account for all of it
especially when you consider that this
problem extends far beyond the airline
industry
every other day there's another video
circulating online of massive bras
breaking out
sometimes in airports and on planes but
also in restaurants
malls anywhere else add to that the much
publicized
videos of people being randomly
assaulted in the street we hear about
the asian victims of these kinds of
crimes but the problem is not limited to
asian victims
and then of course there's the surge in
violent crime across the country
generally as many of our biggest cities
see record numbers of murders assaults
robberies etc
it's not just violent crime either uh
san francisco has seen a rise in
shoplifting
that's so dramatic that it's putting
many stores out of business
the independent reports that walgreens
has had to close down
17 locations just due to so-called petty
theft
speaking of which video posted yesterday
shows a shoplifter
literally loading a garbage bag with
stolen goods
and then casually riding his bike yeah
he rode his bike into the store
riding it out of the store while
security guards look on helplessly
not doing anything about it let's let's
watch some of that footage here
wow now the security guards are filming
it
but it looks like an employee in a
security guard
he makes a kind of lackadaisical attempt
he makes a lackadaisical attempt to grab
the bag but then gives up
and says ah never mind you could take it
and you can hear i think it was the
employees saying should we call 9-1-1
and i don't know whether they called
9-1-1 or not but they probably
didn't because it's been made clear that
the cops are not going to pursue
criminals like this because they're not
going to be prosecuted
now you think about san francisco
between the homeless people defecating
in the street
the heroin addicts throwing their
needles all over the sidewalk
shoplifters strolling out of drug stores
with garbage bags full of merchandise
san francisco is just a lovely place to
live and by lovely i mean it's a
god-forsaken hellscape
not unlike many other cities in this
country and so far
listing all of these things we haven't
we haven't said anything about the
rioting which plagued our cities last
summer and has now coincidentally
tapered
off now that there's a democrat in
office but even so
the precedent has been set that mobs of
opportunistic scumbags can pour into the
street
and set fire to random buildings
whenever they're upset about something
and they'll face almost no consequence
unless they're right wing in which case
even if they're trespassing they're
going to be hunted down by the federal
government
thrown in jail for 20 years and all this
is to say
nothing of the suicide epidemic among
kids which we discussed at some length
yesterday
now add all of this together and what do
you get
not much i suppose except maybe the
breakdown of human society that's all
i mean any one of these factors rioting
homicide epidemic people beating the
hell out of each other on airplanes
may not signify a societal breakdown on
its own but put them all together at the
same time
and i'm not sure what else to call it
the the interesting question is why this
is happening
i think there's really no question that
we're looking at the breakdown of
society
the question really is why and why right
now
as for that i think three contributing
factors should be mentioned though this
is far from an exhaustive list
one you know it's not a coincidence that
many of us
predicted this sort of thing well over a
year ago when the government locked us
all in our homes
we were exactly right but we didn't need
to be profits or fortune tellers to see
it coming
you cannot shut down a society of 330
million people
for any length of time and expected to
start back up again
like nothing happened in sci-fi movies
you can cryogenically freeze an
individual person for a year or 100
years or whatever
and then thaw them out and they'll be
good as new right in the movies but even
in the movies
you can't do that to an entire society
that doesn't work in fiction let alone
reality
there are consequences to such a drastic
and and unnecessary measure
even when you open things back up and
you hope that everything's going to go
back to normal
it doesn't work that way there are going
to be serious consequences catastrophic
consequences in fact
and we're seeing them right now i would
argue
two another factor also
is that trust in and respect for
authority
is probably at an all-time low and some
of that is deserved
nobody trusts or respects our
politicians nor should they but then
police also have been demonized as
departments are defunded and even the
departments that aren't defunded
have trouble recruiting new talent why
would anyone want to be a cop
with the knowledge that they'll be
branded a racist murderer at the outset
and if they ever have to use deadly
force god forbid they may they may well
go to prison for it whether it was
justified or not and if they even if
they don't go to prison for it their
life's gonna be ruined
and three i think the final factor we
should note this is nothing new
but we should mention combined with
these other ingredients
there is the general lack of meaning and
purpose
among so many in our civilization as the
flight from god
and religion theistic religion anyway
continues
so we have a society of people
already in despair many of them from
their sense of meaninglessness
who are then torn out of their normal
lives by a lockdown
which was unnecessary and at the same
time the structures of authority are
destabilized
mix all that together pour it in a pan
stick it in the oven
and this is what you cook up
what's the good news well that was
really the end of
what i had to say i don't have any good
news that's it but i will say this
one thing you can do get out of the
cities
that's for sure move to the country
that's where you need to be let's get
now to our five headlines
well i don't know about you i think
about the things i love doing
during the summer uh i i i do
it it is nice to be inside air
conditioning as much as possible
especially down here in tennessee where
the humidity is like walking into a
brick wall
but if i'm gonna be inside the air
conditioning i don't want to be walking
around uh an auto parts store that's not
where i want to be inside my own house
the great thing about rock auto is if i
need auto parts i can sit
um in the comfort of my own home and
just pull out my phone get on my laptop
and find all the parts i need i don't
need to walk aimlessly around that auto
parts store
ask all these questions about my car i
can't answer any of them
uh because i don't know a lot about cars
and then i get upset i start crying and
i run out of storage happens so many
times
i'm sure it's happened to you and that's
why you need rock auto for a lot of
other reasons too
because they offer the lowest prices
possible they're not changing the prices
they're not going to
you know try to get as much money as
they can out of you it's just if you get
it there it's the lowest price possible
they're a family business and honest
business they've been serving auto parts
customers online
for 20 years you can go to rockauto.com
to shop for auto and body parts from
hundreds of manufacturers
um the catalog is unique and very easy
to navigate so
if you want to experience it for
yourself go to rockauto.com right now
see all the parts available for your car
truck and as always remember to write
walsh in there how did you hear about
xbox so they know
that we sent you all right so
um staying on the bad news
which could really be the name of the
show i guess the bad news with matt
walsh why didn't we think of that
it's just coming to me now
anyway it's probably a little bit hard
to market so
let's go here joe biden is getting ready
for his talk
with putin and he was asked
by a reporter what he plans to say
to putin and i want to show you his
response now
it it we've seen a lot of this kind of
thing from joe biden
so sort of nothing new about it
and we get so used to it you think oh
there there's old joe biden again
having a brain fart no this is not
a brain fart okay this is someone who's
losing their mind experiencing mental
decay
in front of cameras in front of the
whole world
and it's it's bad and embarrassing but
let's
let's watch it first of all
answer the first question i'm laughing
too
they actually uh
well look i mean he has made clear that
the answer is i believe he is in the
past
essentially acknowledged that he was
there certain things that he would do or
did do
what was that i don't even understand
the answer
in in the past he's acknowledged that
there were certain things he would do or
did do
uh okay
what does wood what would do in the past
what does that mean well there's no
point in trying to dissect this or
get into it um this is again someone
who's
experiencing rapid rapid mental decline
in front of the entire world i think at
this point
it's been very obvious all along but now
it seems all but certain
that joe biden
[Music]
most likely is not going to be the
president when we get to 2024
i mean to the not not even voting out of
office but he's not going to be the guy
it's going to be camilla harris
um by the time we get there now
it's really just a question of when it's
really there's two questions now
um when does this official transition of
power happen
and how does it happen we're going to
find out
you know and when it gets to the point
where joe biden
is completely unable to fulfill the
duties of the presidency you could argue
he's at that point right now
but we don't that's the thing we don't
really know how bad it actually is at
this point
we know what we know right now is that
in front of cameras he loses his train
of thought a lot
and then he starts babbling incoherently
and that's and that's pretty disturbing
and that's troubling
but what is it like behind the scenes
when he's not in front of cameras when
he's sitting in his in uh
in the oval office can can he basically
does does he basically have his wits
about him it's possible
but the point is we're not we're not
necessarily going to know whether
there's a there's a line
we don't know where the line is where he
is no longer able to fulfill the duties
of the presidency
uh where is that line when has when does
he cross it has he already crossed it
and will we be told when he crosses it
this is a full-on constitutional crisis
that we're looking at potentially
we may already be in one
and what makes this so frustrating is
just like the consequences of the
lockdown
this is so foreseeable of course this is
going to happen
when you when you elect a 78-year-old
man who's already in cognitive decline
and then you take him and you put him in
the most stressful job
on earth we've all
unfortunately most of us have because
because
alzheimer's is so common dementia is so
common um
most of us have had experience with
seeing this with loved ones
and so you know if you have say your
grandfather or grandmother
who went through this you know how
quickly you start seeing the warning
signs
and then it and it's kind of like
they're gradually headed to this cliff
and then they fall off the cliff
and it happens very fast and you know
that that happens when your
grandfather your grandmother is retired
and they're sitting at home all day
playing with the grandkids
free life still
the decline is exponential
until you fall off the cliff and it's
like they just aren't even there anymore
and it's very sad um okay so we know
that x that that happens exponentially
with a retired person in a stress-free
life
what about when you when you put them in
in one of the most physically and
mentally demanding jobs
on the planet and also one of the most
consequential and important jobs on the
planet
it's just crazy
we knew this was going to happen of
course it's going to happen
and even a lot of even plenty of
conservatives who are biden critics
i i i've been making this point all
along i'm certainly not the only one but
those of us who've been making this
point about joe biden these two old
i can only speak for myself but i've i
heard from a lot of
even conservatives saying yeah you know
i don't like joe biden
but that's not the reason that that's
not the reason not to vote for him
let's not be ageist okay
my my grandmother is uh 85 and she's
sharp as attack
a lot of that kind of nonsense yeah
you're right that there were a lot of
other reasons not to vote for joe biden
but actually you didn't really need any
other reasons
because the fact that he's 78 is reason
enough
you simply should not be electing 78
year olds to the presidency and we
should
never do this again it's embarrassing
it's humiliating
it's catastrophic you're asking for
a crisis on 10 different levels
and you're going to get it there are
realities
i don't want to hear any of this it's
ageism oh shut up
it's not ageism to to acknowledge the
reality
of of of age it's not ageist
to simply notice that age exists
and there are certain realities that
come with it because we are mortal
creatures
living in a physical frame that
deteriorates over time i know it's not
fun to think about nobody likes to think
about it but it's true
your 85 year old grandmother is sharp as
attack for an 85 year old
not in general she's not as sharp as she
was when she was 45 she wasn't she's not
nobody is
unless she unless you're telling me
she's literally superhuman
bring her to a to uh we gotta discover
she's discovered the the elixir of
immortality bring her to a lab somewhere
maybe we could
figure out what's going on um aside from
that
she may be sharba's attack for an 85
year old
that that doesn't mean that at her age
she is suited to do one of the most
stressful important jobs
on planet earth okay
okay sharpest attack for an 85 year old
means that they can hold a conversation
and you know they can play with the
grandkids and all that kind of stuff
which is great
i hope that i can do all that when i'm
85 i hope i'm still alive when i'm 85.
that doesn't mean you put them in the in
the oval office we we should after 80
we shouldn't even have to talk about
whether 80 year olds should be president
of course not
80 year olds shouldn't even be driving
okay in a sane society you wouldn't have
that
this is this we we cannot can we all and
i know we can't agree to it because
that's the other frustrating thing
we should after this experience we
should all be able to agree we are never
doing this
again we are not going to elect a 78
year old
nobody should turn 80 in the oval office
nobody
i wish we could agree we could make a
pinky promise with each other but we
can't
can we because you know the the elephant
in the room
here is that uh i say we shouldn't elect
the 78 year old to
the presidency ever again i mean it but
uh
donald trump will be 78 in 2024.
am i applying this to him yes absolutely
because he is also a mortal creature
who is susceptible to physical and
mental decline like anybody is
all right let's go to number two from
the daily wire
uh reading now it says california
gubernatorial candidate caitlyn jenner
slammed
late night host jimmy kimmel after he
called jenner trump in a wig
during his show on thursday night kimmel
celebrated the end of keeping up with
kardashians which ran for 20 seasons
across 14
years and inspired 10 spin-offs 10
spin-offs
of keeping up with the kardashians
i didn't even know there was one there's
10.
my lord kimmel said um anyway i'm not
gonna repeat his jokes cause it's
not even really funny but he then he
then he made a joke that uh
caitlyn jenner is donald trump in a wig
and then there was some outrage
about that but but not from the left of
course it was from the right
and jenner called out kimmel the left
and the lgbt community on twitter on
friday
he tweeted quote last night jimmy kimmel
called me donald trump with a wig
he obviously believes that trans women
are simply men with wigs on
well where's the outrage from the left
or lgbt community
being woke must be optional if you're a
democrat
and of course there as i said plenty of
people on the right
jump jumping on this bandwagon and
saying oh where where's this is
transphobia where where's the outrage
from the left
where's the outrage uh
and yes okay
it is hypocrisy of course it is
we we all understand that if
jimmy kimmel had made this joke about
any
other trans person um
that that i can even think of because
all the other ones that come to mind are
on the left
uh any other you know prominent trans
person in in the public eye or
not problematic if he had chosen any
other target for that joke
who's transgender and it's not caitlyn
jenner
yes there would be there would be
tremendous outrage on the left and he
would be uh
well the joke never would have been made
in the first place so we don't have to
think about it but if somehow it was
then there'd be tremendous outrage and
he'd be forced to issue an apology and
all the rest of it
calling calling a a a quote-unquote
trans woman
a man in a wig yes from the left in
every other circumstance
they're gonna call that blatant
transphobia and it's unacceptable and
it's probably a hate crime
however um
so does that mean that we on the right
should jump on this bandwagon and say
hey this is transphobia
we're outraged by it why aren't you
you guys are the real transphobes should
we be doing that should we do that whole
routine
the answer is no we shouldn't and i'll
tell you why two reasons number one
and this is something we all need to try
to understand and keep in mind
the left they don't care about their
hypocrisy
not only do they not care about it but
it's the point
the hypocrisy is the point
because that shows their cultural power
what they're saying is
we make the rules yeah obviously the
rules don't apply to us like they do to
you
thanks for noticing we're the ones in
charge
yeah clearly we don't care in general
about quote unquote transphobia
this is a this is a tool that we use to
bludgeon our opponents
you're our opponents we're not going to
bludgeon ourselves with the tool
that's the left they will all but come
out and say that
it's clearly their strategy so by
pointing out
by merely pointing out the hypocrisy in
this way it doesn't achieve much because
it yeah we all know it but they know it
too
and so what's the point the hypocrisy is
the point
because it's all about power
that's the first problem with the
democrats are the real transphobe thing
the second is that in order to
criticize the left on their own
grounds right by throwing their own
labels back at them
and i understand the temptation to do
this because you're saying uh
well yeah we're gonna we're gonna make
them take a dose of their own medicine
we're gonna
hold them to their own standard and all
this kind of stuff the problem
is that to criticize them on their terms
not only is it ineffectual because they
don't care
but also it requires you to adopt their
presuppositions
it it it by by criticizing them on their
terms they've already won
because you're agreeing with them
so the left they can when they hear when
they hear people on the right
non-ironically using the term
transphobia
the left they can sit back and say well
our work here is done
you suckers you think when you start
calling them transphobes they're
they're they're cowering in fear oh no
they're calling us transphobes what will
we do
we've been defeated we've been bested at
our own game oh drat
we would have got away with it too if
not for you darn kids
no not at all they're saying okay thank
you
thanks for agreeing with us
by using a term like transphobia you're
agreeing with them you're seeding the
point
you're surrendering the ground you're
adopting their philosophical
presupposition
presuppositions
what on the right what we should know is
that first of all transphobia is not a
thing
i'm not going to accuse anyone of being
a transphobe that's not a thing
phobe is fear no one's afraid of trans
people
the people like myself who are critical
of the concept
of transgenderism it's not it's not out
of fear it's out of understanding of
science and logic
it's a logical criticism not a
fear-based one
and also frankly observing
that a male
with long hair is not a woman that's not
bigotry
even if it's hypocritical coming from
jimmy kimmel it's still not bigotry
and so i'm not going to say that it is
even an attempt to score a point against
jimmy kimmel because you're not going to
score the point anyway
all right let's move on to uh
anna navarro okay we got to play this
anna navarro on the view yesterday was
offering a defense of speaking of double
standards
here we go um was offering a defense of
jeffrey toobin
masturbating in front of his co-workers
um
and there's no way to really set this up
we just have to we have to listen
and gawk in amazement at uh at this
rationalization
are you surprised to see him back on the
air
you know actually i'm not surprised he's
back on the air but i will tell you when
i saw that interview
oh god how embarrassing how humiliating
i i kept thinking to myself if i have to
go
on live tv and explain to the nation why
i masturbated on assume call i think i'd
rather go sell avocados under i-95
than get my job back on tv look um
i think some instances of sexual
harassment
are black and white some instances are
uh
more nuanced in this case uh he was not
sexually harassing
anybody he didn't have the intent to
sexually harass somebody he was sexually
harassing himself
uh maybe okay he was on a soon call
he was an accidental exposure it was not
a cnn zoom call it was with the new
yorker from where
he has been terminated and faced
consequences he was off cnn for many
months
during the elections during some of the
hottest political and legal
times cnn is a for-profit business if
viewers don't like it
then they should make their views known
if they want to have some grace
if they want to say we're not going to
cancel a guy because he made
a stupid mistake i think i think his
bigger problem
is frankly with himself with his family
with his wife
than it is um with his cnn colleagues
because it was not something that was
done
to us
more nuanced this is not uh
this is not black and white sexual
harassment okay
well black and white sexual harassment
is you wanna talk about black and white
straightforward that's like
a male co-worker tells a female
co-worker that she looks nice in that
dress
that's straightforward no nuance there
okay that right there now you want to
know
that's me too movement material that
someone needs to be fired probably
arrested
put them in send them down to gitmo
but uh yeah we gotta there there are
more nuanced uh
situations like a guy masturbating in
front of his covers
now if he were to to compliment her on
her dress again straightforward
but but masturbating in front of her
okay see that now it's we're getting
into the nuances
and it's just it's hard can you condemn
it can you
can we cast aspersions
let he who has not masturbated in front
of co-workers cast the first stone
then she just gets pelted by a million
stones
yeah this is obviously ridiculous
i just talked about the the
fruitlessness of pointing out double
standards so
i'm not gonna have my own double
standard by doing the same here now we
got double standards all over the place
it's like an inception situation with
double standards but
i i i you can't gloss over
this the most straightforward
form of sexual harassment i would think
is what jeffrey tubin did
it's the most black and white sexual
harassment that one can imagine and i'd
rather not imagine it
i i have to i have to uh under
underscore the point again
because there's some uh there's some
gaslighting going on here
to use a favorite phrase of the left
there's some gasoline going on when they
talk about the jeffrey toobin thing
because they keep saying it was an
accident
he didn't mean to well
what part of it was an accident
the part where he took off his pants and
i'm not going to go into all the details
but you know
that whole process that was not an
accident
i mean what does he have some sort of
masturbatory tourette syndrome where he
just he can't stop himself
no so that part was purposeful
what part was unpurposeful uh that he
didn't know his camera was on okay so
that's the unpurposeful part
but the other purposeful part is he was
doing this during a
meeting with his co-workers they were on
the screen
i don't want to speculate okay the last
thing i want to do
is uh is try to walk a mile
in jeffrey toobin's messy shoes and to
understand exactly where he was coming
from
but no pun intended there
but however it's it seems to me that he
was
doing this during a meeting with his
co-workers
and they were up on the screen so it
seems like he was
i don't know watching them while doing
this
all of that was intentional he just
didn't want them to know he was doing it
and so because of that the whole thing's
an accident
this is like if a guy it's like what if
jeffrey toobin was
outside of one of his co-workers window
at night
peering through the bushes and then and
then anna navarro would say it was an
accident he didn't
do that no he didn't know he didn't mean
to be caught
that's the distinction the camera being
on that's him being caught
all right i've said far too much now
we're going to hear from
a new sponsor which we're excited about
on the show myphoto.com
after a tough year people are together
again they're taking a lot of photos
uh in in in my case in my
family it's we've been taking a lot of
photos all along i don't really take the
photos but my wife is the photo taker
no matter what we're doing she's always
saying we got to take the picture well
here's here's the problem
you take a picture and then it's just on
your phone and you forget about it right
what you need to do is take that picture
and make it physical and that's what my
photo
is all about it's awesome and it's easy
to use it takes literally two minutes to
create a special product for your own
wall or shelf or wherever
and they make great gifts for loved ones
my photo prints your image directly on
acrylic glass metal and more don't just
have all those photos
on your phone stored away somewhere make
them make them into an actual physical
photograph kids that's what we used to
have back in the day
you need to go to myphoto.com and check
it out that's myphoto.com order today
you'll get 20
off your order which will arrive in just
five days and if you're looking for a
father's day gift
no doubt dad will love one of these from
you prices start at just
twelve dollars use code walsh and get 20
off today
let's move on to reading
the youtube comments uh okay
this from uh big mac
says matt would you rather eat a bird
eat at burger king or at the soup
kitchen jeffrey tube and volunteers at
well i
just said i wanted to move on but i
imagine the problem you'd have with
jeffrey tube and serving you
is is
not dissimilar from the kind of problem
you might have being served at a burger
king
so it's kind of a wash frederick
landslot says
matt can we get a tie-dye tuesday it's
what the people want no
and you're banned and nobody wants that
except for you you freak
but thanks for watching molly says matt
kids
are being taught that slavery is okay as
long as it's uh through communism
very good point and you are you are
correct about that another comment says
matt do you think the ghost of abuela
will haunt aoc
after abuela dies well the last thing i
want to do is
is think about such a uh such an
eventuality but
uh i i what i will say is that i would
if i were
the boiler in that scenario uh
jay moran says you ever noticed the
people who drone on and on about slavery
always leave out the part where we
abolished it
yeah they leave it out or they uh they
especially leave out the little detail
how the united states is uh is
abolished slavery quicker than
almost any other country right
we abolished slavery in about what 90
years or so less than a century we
abolished it
a century from the united states forming
as a country
you are from there to the the abolition
of slavery and you've got
less than a century okay
meanwhile you've got other countries
across the world
who've that that practice slavery for
thousands of years
and some still do in effect
you know slavery is technically
abolished and illegal at this point
everywhere although it's still practiced
in a lot of places
if not legally but it wasn't even
abolished
legally in some places until
the last several decades
and those places are not western
countries i have to tell you
oliska says i will not write more
comments i don't think matt reads them
you're right i don't read them at all
uh olives says
matt walsh's sarcasm is to hide the fact
that he has a massive
caring heart no no it's not
and reagan says matt was far too nice in
understanding this episode i almost
believe he has feelings what's going on
here
so my brand has been damaged these are
all lies by the way
there were several comments like this
accusing me of being nice and caring
yesterday what
how when when did that when was the nice
and caring part
that's why i had to be even more
aggressive and uh and uh
you know depressing this episode just to
just to kind of even things out again
and maintain my reputation
uh and finally mason says it's funny
that no one talks about how the irish
were oppressed
well mason that's not possible i don't
know what you mean the irish were
oppressed
irish aren't black are they they're
white aren't they
white people can't experience
suppression this is a
critical race theory taught me that so i
don't know what i don't know what you
could possibly be talking about
after a year of lockdowns it's become i
think fairly clear that our leaders want
nothing more than to control us
uh i would know because if i was a
tyrannical dictator i'd do the exact
same thing except
i would be controlling you for your own
good that's the difference
right oh no way that's exactly what all
tyrants say okay well
um but because i'm not i i do enjoy our
freedoms which is why you need to pick
up
ben shapiro's new book the authoritarian
moment listen
if a theocratic fascist is telling you
to pick up a book criticizing
authoritarianism
then you must do it i mean you really
must do it because i'm telling you to do
it
so if you understand the threat this
poses to our future it's time to read up
on the truth in order to stand up to the
woke the authoritarian moment is now
available for pre-order at amazon barnes
noble and any other major bookseller
also we'll tell you about something
something else exciting happening here
at the daily wire
um we know that leftism turns men and
women
into creatures that resemble addicts of
some sort you know blue hair
gender non-conforming whatever it may be
this isn't this is not the exciting part
i'll get that in a second
but thankfully some renounce it before
that transformation
that transformation fully takes place
and sometimes can become permanent
georgia howe is one of those people and
now she has a new show
at the daily wire called office hours
where she interviews various experts
about the ideological indoctrination of
the left through the unique lens of a
former member
if you're a conservative like me you
probably have a job so we made sure
i don't know about anybody else but we
we do anyway so we made sure that you
could listen anywhere
you can listen to podcasts you can
listen to the podcast version anywhere
anywhere you go
from discussing critical race theory to
transgenderism uh
all the crazy things that are happening
in our education system and everything
else
you gotta watch or listen to office
hours so subscribe and download office
hours with georgia howe on apple podcast
or whatever your platform of choice
may be and get ready for the ultimate
listening experience no matter where you
are
now let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
so we begin our daily cancellation day
with an account on twitter called
astrologer 6.
in her bio she describes herself as an
inclusive astrologer
inclusive and also an intimacy doula
coincidentally i have both of those
titles listed on my resume as well
but i fear that she's making her fellow
inclusive astrologers look bad
with this tweet she posted quote i
finished a book about how modern dating
is arguably
unpaid sex work and woo woo
i believe the woos are meant to be meant
to signify approval must be some kind of
technical
astrologer term i don't know as for the
rest all i can say is that the word
arguably is doing a whole lot of work in
that sentence
she reveals in a follow-up that the name
of the book written by maura
weigel is uh it's titled labor of love
the invention of dating and as far as i
could tell from my extensive research
which involved skimming a summary of the
book for about 25 seconds
it does indeed make the case that the
inclusive astrologer claims dating is
nothing but
unpaid prostitution and this is not the
only notable bit of prostitution related
content on twitter this week
i also want to mention this and then
i'll respond to and cancel both
naomi sayers a lawyer though
suspiciously enough she fails to specify
whether she's an inclusive lawyer
she tweeted this unpopular opinion
the best thing young people can do
earlier in their careers is do sex work
on the side
because your early career prospects will
be unstable unpredictable
low pay likely contract work and very
much exploitative
the best thing not an acceptable thing
or an understandable thing
and that would be bad and wrong enough
the best
thing she says and you'll notice this is
always the flight path
of leftism right first they argue that
some degenerate activity is tolerable
and they they simply want you to
tolerate it and put up with it and let
people do what they want to do in the
privacy of their own homes
or or their own uh cd motel rooms in
this case
and then they say uh no no it's more
than tolerable it's a positive good
and then finally they claim that it's
more than a positive good it's the best
thing it's the ideal thing
normalization is never the final goal
normalization is a step
towards the goal they don't want to make
a bad thing
merely normal they want to make it
laudable virtuous
we may not be at that point yet with sex
work um where
at least we may not be at the point yet
where most of society views
quote-unquote sex work that way
but especially with the advent of only
fans and the continued proliferation of
online pornography
we've probably reached the normalized
phase at least
in fact the first hint that they've
succeeded in normalizing sex work is the
fact that people call it sex work rather
than prostitution
and by the way when we say normalized we
don't just mean that a certain
sin is normal in the sense that lots of
people do it i mean in that sense
prostitution has been normal since time
immemorial but
um and all sin has been normal in that
way in in the sense that people do them
what we mean is normal in the sense that
society doesn't look down on it doesn't
judge it
doesn't view it as especially dirty or
degraded
and that's probably where we are with
prostitution and that's a problem
for many reasons but two of them are
illustrated quite helpfully in the
tweets already mentioned
first as the inclusive astrologer or at
least the book she's reading says
dating is unpaid sex work that's the
claim
this is the kind of view that you find
once once quote unquote sex work
prostitution
becomes more and more normalized you
find these kinds of things being equated
but saying that dating is unpaid sex
work it's like saying that parenting
is unpaid babysitting or it's like
saying that cooking a nice meal for your
family is unpaid restaurant work
or having a conversation with a friend
is like being an unpaid
podcast co-host i don't know it terms it
turns all forms of human exchange into
business deals
it makes all relationships transactional
naomi sayers the lawyer says that the
best thing a young person can do
is sell their bodies for money and she
says this is better than other career
prospects because
those other careers might be unstable
and exploitative of course the obvious
irony is that prostitution is the
very definition of exploitation
the the people who wish to normalize
prostitution
will say and this this argument is very
common now
this is what miami sayers are saying
well say there's no difference between
literally whoring yourself out and say
working at mcdonald's
but there's a very clear difference when
you work at mcdonald's
you're being hired and paid to perform a
task
to do a certain thing as a prostitute
you are the thing that is being done
you aren't selling your services or your
skill set you're selling your body
itself your body is the product
the object the inventory on the shelf
if you work at old navy right you're
selling clothes
if you work as a prostitute you're
taking off your clothes and selling
what's underneath
and what's underneath it is you your
body yourself
the prostitute offers her body up as a
glorified
masturbatory aid a breathing sex doll
essentially
to be exploited and used and then
discarded by a stranger
there is a major difference here it's
the difference between being an employee
and a slave it's the difference between
selling an object
and being one there are those who don't
want you to notice the difference
they seek to elevate prostitution by
degrading
all other work and this is always the
method right lift up what is dirty
and wrong by pulling the whole world
down to its level
we should definitely resist those kinds
of attempts
and to those who are attempting it we
should say
all together now you're canceled
and we'll leave it there for today
thanks for watching thanks for listening
have a great day godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
our technical director is austin stevens
production manager pavel vadasky
the show is edited by sasha tolmachov
our audio is mixed by mike coromina
hair makeup is done by nika geneva and
our production coordinator is mckenna
waters
the matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 21.
the comedian john lovitz incorrectly
compares cancel culture
to mccarthyism cnn tries to mainstream
another pervert squishes defend critical
race theory and the fed
cancels the founding fathers check it
out on the michael knowles show